a man already registered as a sex
offender is accused of sexually
assaulting a child and the 8 news now
i-team has uncovered multiple warning
signs the i-team's vanessa murphy in
studio she obtained one document which
may indicate the suspect should have
remained in custody in the first place
she's here with what she's uncovered
denise and brian willie collins was
considered high risk five months ago but
still a judge made a decision to allow
him to walk the streets now as you
mentioned police say he sexually
assaulted a child walking to school
willie collins makes his first court
appearance after metro police say he
sexually assaulted a boy walking to
school thursday approached the mail
our victim
and he
simulated that he had a firearm and said
that he would kill the victim if he did
not comply with his request
he then directed the victim to a back
alley this isn't colin's first time in
court in fact police say he was wearing
an ankle monitor he was accused of
robbery in september this pre-trial risk
assessment obtained by the 8 news now
i-team is aimed at preparing judges with
information as they decide whether to
grant bail it indicates collins is high
risk and a flight risk in court
documents 15 previous arrests are noted
and that collins was homeless but could
stay with a friend
still north las vegas justice court
judge kalani who set his bail at
15-hundred dollars and house arrest
giving him the freedom to walk out of
jail collins is also a registered sex
offender for a sex crime against
children dating back to 2017. police say
at least one of the victims had special
needs on friday a prosecutor refers to
an additional pending case as collins is
accused of having sex with another
inmate just part of colin's lengthy
criminal history 13 prior misdemeanor
convictions 10 prior failures to appear
collins next court date is set for march
first in the meantime he'll remain in
custody i just want to say
thank you
judge thank you thank you
my public defender thank you everybody
here and i know
a prosecutor says collins said he
attacked the child because he was white
which will likely lead to a hate crime
charge right now collins faces 12
charges in connection with the alleged
attack including sexual assault
kidnapping battery and more back to you